WESLEY CHUN: Hey, welcome back
to our series on using G Suite
developer tools for
student developers.
In this segment, we'll look at
using G Suite REST APIs along
with code samples.
I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
If you missed the
overview video,
check it out first because
there we show you how to get
started, getting credentials
and creating projects
using G Suite APIs.
Now we're going to dive in,
starting with Google Drive.
Here's code that lists the
first 100 files and folders
in your Google Drive.
Believe it or not,
the real application
is really just the
last three lines.
Everything else is just
the security boilerplate
we covered earlier plus a
requested scopes and API
endpoint creation.
Once you have an endpoint
to the Drive API,
it's as simple as creating a
file listing query, executing
that query, and
displaying the results.
If you want to build
this app line by line
check out the Code Map.
Heads up, Google's upgrading
to newer client libraries
to bring the GCP and G Suite
worlds closer together.
While the current libraries will
stay operational for a while,
you need to see how
the code changes.
So here's the exact same example
but with the newer libraries.
As you can see, aside from
a couple of import changes,
managing the OAuth
tokens yourself,
everything else stays
mostly the same.
The G Suite docs already
reflect this change
but bear in mind that most
of the code in the wild
still uses the original
libraries, including
the deep dive video linked here.
While this sample
is in Python, you
can guess that
the client library
upgrades like this apply
regardless of what language
you use.
OK, now that you've
seen some code let's
take a step back and think why
you would use the Drive API?
Well, one reason
could be, you want
to write an app that
backs up zip files
but expands them in
flight to Google Drive.
Well, this is an actual
JavaScript sample app.
Check out its open source
repo if interested.
Another example, let's say you
get a job at a startup helping
people automate photo albums.
Well, you'd pitch that everyone
who gets back from vacation
have to empty out their
cameras and phones
to an external hard drive.
And what do all those
pictures look like on disk?
A big unorganized mess, right?
But if you use the Drive
API to access file metadata
like the timestamp and
geolocation, you and your team
could actually build an app that
auto generates photo albums!
Now taking it a step further,
stitch those photos together
into a video, upload it
with the YouTube API,
then use the Gmail API to
tell your friends and family.
Get an idea of what you can
do with Google APIs now?
It's as limitless
as your imagination.
Each Google API has
official documentation.
And the G Suite ones live at
developers.google.com/ whatever
the API name is, such as Drive.
The docs are structured
via guides tab that
feature quick starts
in multiple languages
as well as guides for
specific API features.
Now beyond the quick starts
are more fully fleshed
out sample apps.
These live under the
samples tab for each API
and links to any open source
repos or developer videos.
Now if you need
help, the Support tab
links to stack
overflow, or issue
tracker for bugs and
feature requests,
or perhaps communities of
like minded developers.
Next, let's move
to the Sheets API.
After all, aren't spreadsheets
the most programmable
of all the productivity apps?
You may have data sitting
in a database or a CSV file,
but those form
factors aren't exactly
visually appealing, right?
Do you really want to tell
your boss to select star
from your database?
Well, spreadsheets are a common
and simple user interface
that feature tabular data.
And JavaScript developers
can try the API code
lab that lets you build
a customized reporting
tool for a fictitious
toy manufacturer.
Now in this code
sample, we're going
to reuse that toy order
database and migrate it
to a spreadsheet.
Again, the OAuth code will
be the same as before,
but switched with the Sheet's
rewrite scope and its API
endpoint.
Now as you can see, the first
half of the code snippet
queries for the toy order
data while the second half
creates a new sheet and
pushes the data there.
Check out the video for
more on this sample.
Don't forget to
enable the API first!
Moving on, why the Slides API?
Well the same reason as Sheets
but taking it a step further.
Yes, Sheets is definitely
more visual than a database
but isn't a slide deck the
ultimate in visualization?
Or maybe you're organizing
your school's hackathon
and want to create only
one master slide deck when
seeking corporate sponsorships.
Or you're a sales person
who's giving the same pitch
to multiple clients.
Well, why not create one
master template deck,
then auto generate
customized decks
for each sponsor or customer?
Now here's that code snippet,
replacing the placeholder
variables with actual data,
whether it's the customer
name or corporate logo.
Now this one's also got a
video for further study.
In real life you
can probably guess
this isn't the whole thing.
And you will need to
use more than one API.
Well, think about it.
Don't you have to
call the Drive API
to copy the master template,
then get the customer
or sponsor information
from the Sheets API,
then generate the slide
deck with the Slides API?
Well, this pseudocode
answers the obvious question
of how to set up using more
than one API at a time.
Now here's another
example using two APIs.
Here, we take data and a
chart from a spreadsheet
and add them to a slide deck.
The video also shows how to read
the data from the Sheets API
first.
Now the Docs API
is a perfect tool
for creating a mail merge tool.
Similar to the
customer Slide decks,
let's say you got a form letter
with variable placeholders
like this.
Then you have a sheet with
the data for each recipient.
Well, here's the heart
of the mail merge code.
Look how similar it is
to the Slides example.
Once you copy the
master template doc
and read the data
from the sheet,
it's not much effort to fill
in those variable placeholders.
Now this video doesn't
go over the code
but you can get a link to
the app's open source repo.
Once it's done
executing you should
have an individual Google Doc
with all the substitutions
made.
All you need to do is call the
Drive API to export it as PDF,
then build an email message
with this attachment,
and then send it
with the Gmail API.
All right, so that's our quick
tour of G Suite REST APIs.
To learn more about others,
check out our landing page.
In the next episode, we'll cover
a higher level platform that
lets you access G Suite
APIs with just objects
and not have to worry as much
about authorization code.
Join us as we tell you
about Google Apps Script.
This is Wesley Chun from Google,
and we'll see you next time.